good morning i'm adam laxalt
i am a former navy and iraq veteran
and the former top law enforcement
officer of this state
i care deeply about both the rule of law
and voter integrity
like the rest of nevadans and americans
and we warned for the last few weeks
that we could end up in a situation
where nevada decides
the fate of the presidency we warned
that the democrats changed this election
system
they gave us mail-in ballots and
despite the fact that there are examples
of thousands of ballots
being mailed across this valley in trash
cans in apartment buildings
people getting as many as 18 ballots to
their homes
we knew these these roles were unclean
and we were told that signatures
would save us from all fraud but to date
we still have not been able to observe
these signatures or or meaningfully
challenge
a single male in ballot out of hundreds
of thousands of castes
we firmly believe that there are many
voters
in this group of mail-in people that are
not
proper voters in the last many days
we have received reports of many
irregularities
across the valley we've we believe that
there are dead voters
that have been counted we are also
confident that there are thousands
of people whose votes have been counted
that have moved out of clark county
in the during the pandemic
today we have a voter jill stokey
who was denied access to vote
she showed up to vote and she was told
someone had already
cast her ballot and she was denied the
opportunity
to vote we are filing in federal
district court here in las vegas we're
asking for
emergency relief a tro and injunctive
relief we're asking the judge to
do to all of these irregularities to
stop the counting
of improper votes
thank you the courts of nevada can you
wait
look the reality is is that transparency
is not political
ballots are not automatically legal
votes
until they're checked we are not being
allowed to check
the harry reid machine recklessly
threw ballots into the mail and now we
cannot check
whether or not there are non-residents
which we have
evidence publicly available evidence
that you all in the media should be also
looking at
it's publicly available information that
non-residents have voted
there is a 30-day residency requirement
in the state of nevada if you haven't
been in the state for 30 days it is
illegal
to vote reporters have a responsibility
the fact is we are filing this federal
lawsuit
to protect legal voters
it is unacceptable in this country to
have
illegal votes counted
and that is what's happening in the
state of nevada
we've asked clark county for answers
they have no answers
they continue to count illegal
votes that is unacceptable
and it's giving legal people
a sense that the system is corrupt
we have to have a system where legal
votes are cast
what the harry reid machine has done is
throw out
recklessly ballots
and now they don't want us to check
those ballots
and we are seeing discrepancies all over
we are asking clark county to give us
answers
all of your questions about the details
are legitimate questions and they should
be asked of clark county because the
clark county officials
are silent they are not giving us any
answers and they continue to count these
illegal
votes ballots versus
legal votes that's what we're talking
about
it is unacceptable in this country
thank you all for turning out thank you
all for turning out the presidency
literally hangs in the balance and what
the fundamental principle is here
is that we want to be able to make sure
that the counting that occurs and that
the results that happen
can be respected by every american voter
across this land
and truly across the world if you're not
allowed in to see the process
both sides and all of you in the media
so that there is transparency
so that there's meaningful observing of
these ballots
that calls into question what those
results will be
the idea in this country the idea in
america
that we would somehow reduce or limit
the ability
to have basic insurance
that a ballot is a legal ballot that a
ballot is an acceptable ballot
that the person who voted that we took
minimal steps to make sure that there
was a signature match for instance
those types of of guarantees need to be
in
the process and so we have to understand
that what's going on
in nevada impacts what's going on
all across this country which is the
american people want to have
confidence in the results that are
coming out of nevada
that will occur when we can make a case
why every ballot is an acceptable
compliant ballot
do you want to introduce these two or we
can have them introduce themselves
these are individuals who have
stories of discrepancy if you want to
state your name and briefly
uh what happened okay and we won't take
any any
questions but you can step up and go
right here
hi my name is jill stokey i went to vote
and was told
i already voted i pursued the matter
and in years past i always voted in
person
this time they mailed out the ballot and
somebody
took my ballot they also took the ballot
of my roommate
i was told by the interviewer from
channel 8
when i said did other people do this he
said yes
he said you're the first double thank
you
miss stokely spell your name for us
please s's and sam tias and tom
o kke
good good morning i'm uh chris padom i'm
going to give my account
uh what happened i was here uh actually
been here
quite a bit and was here with uh members
of the trump campaign and
and came in immediate capacity to obtain
content information on election night
and unfortunately was a stereotype in
that regard
uh and you can take for that what you
may
and was not able to obtain any type of
access by any means
and it got a little bit i guess you can
say assertive or aggressive is the word
so to speak
and the question was asked at 1 30 in
the morning why are you here
and our response was well it's election
night that's why we're here and you guys
are obviously counting ballots
and it was unique because they said they
had an hour and a half
left of counting to do and an official
came out
who was kind and accessed to sign
documents
and a few moments later we were asked to
leave
well i find that ironically react to
leave within 10 to 12
minutes when they said they had an hour
and a half of counting left to do and
clearly that was an attack
i think on any type of conservative
media or any individual or entity that
wanted to have access and cover
and we find it very unique that other
outlets are able to
have full access but we were not giving
any type of access what's the mean
and they and they question the validity
of my
uh background or any type of media any
type of experience whatsoever so
that was my personal account and that's
it so what's your name
let me um let me just let me just say
this
all of your questions are very good and
they should be asked of clark county
we don't have access to the information
they are not giving us
access to the ballots the publicly
available information
raises a lot of questions
and yet we are not getting answers just
like you we're not going to take
any more questions today and i will say
that we will have more to say at the end
of the day after we filed any evidence
so all you have to do is ask your
questions of clark county
and we will make sure that we continue
the pressure on them too
thank you very much